les templiers d'elancourt en mode
rouleau compresseur les élans courtois
n'ont pas fait de détail ce samedi 22
février à domicile contre les dockers de
nantes
les élans courtois l'emportent sur le
score de 51 0 après avoir dominé
l'ensemble de la partie c'est une belle
victoire
on a on a été plein partout autant en
défense qu'en attaque
franchement ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir de voir que mes coéquipiers
prennent du plaisir et du coup voilà on
a on a montré ce qu'on avait à montrer
maintenant certes on a fait beaucoup de
fautes mais on va apprendre de nos
erreurs et référent essayer de faire
nous au classement les templiers
d'elancourt se replace cette troisième
victoire en quatre matches leur permet
d'occuper la deuxième place de leur
poule derrière les léopards de rouen les
playoffs de fin de saison sont donc
accessibles ainsi qu'une montée en
première division c'est un objectif
maintenant on en est encore loin là
c'est plutôt en phase de playoffs on
pourra avoir une vraie indication sur
sûr sur cette question mais ça reste un
de nos objectifs maintenant c'est une
marche qui est très très hot
on a encore beaucoup de beaucoup de
travail et pas mal de matches mais on va
on va pousser en fait au plus loin pour
pour atteindre cet objectif
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le 1er mars sur le terrain
des diables rouges de villepinte
en attendant les élans courtois peuvent
savourer
[Applaudissements]